be with Food and Drug Administration
announced an Adderall shortage back in
October today local families dealing
with ADHD continue to scramble to find a
pharmacy with the medication in stock
Candace Charles joins us live from
Summerlin tonight with the impacts of
the shortage and advice from a local
psychiatrist Candice
Sasha this is something that can impact
all of us really in November the FDA
said there will be about 30 or 60 more
days until we see more Adderall back on
the shelves but families continue to
struggle to find a solution especially
those on a low income and pharmacies
continue to have a hard time filling up
their shelves the Activa the largest
manufacturer of the drug says they've
been experiencing ongoing intermittent
manufacturing delays but both the
company and the FDA say a huge increase
in demand has made it hard for
manufacturers to keep up and the FDA
wants to ensure the increase in demand
is legitimate the excuse me the Nevada
mental health medical director tells me
diagnoses are becoming more common but
that could be because people are
becoming more aware about ADD and ADHD
and that pharmacies throughout the
valley are constantly checking and
trying to get the medication back on the
shelves
there is hope
um but the disruption is what's
important I give the example if my
patient does not have the medication for
one week that might be enough for them
to get fired
or a kid to get in trouble in school and
miss out few days of school so there is
an impact
Dr says
the impact that could have effects not
only on patients but the general public
He suggests Ritalin as an alternative
especially for children He suggests
working with your physician to find
Alternatives at this moment until we get
more Adderall back on the shelf and the
FDA does have a list of alternatives on
their website we'll have those details
on our website newsnow.com for now in
Sun City Summerlin I'm Candice Charles 8
News Now